hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't escape for
days in the wasteland it is day 2 also a
helicopter just moved itself into the
building that we're in so we got to go
up and see what's going on with that up
there and I'm thinking that we could
also recover some of the nails Oh Oh an
extension cord oh that's good don't know
why I need that what's in my journal I
survived the night only to have another
weird dream it was a wave of heat a
surge of hot air that burned through my
skin I swear I was able to feel my sweat
boiling if there's another prophecy I
have to find a way to cool down my
hideout if that wasn't enough I think
something just crashed into the roof I
have to find a way to cool down my
hideout okay that's weird you probably
shouldn't rely your entire defense on
that dream alone because that's really
weird if I plan my life around every
dream I had I would have a lot more
friends and be jumping off of a lot more
buildings oh whoa whoa whoa okay whoa
easy nice landing so you're gonna shoot
me now aren't you considering the fact
that was flying on fumes and half the
controls were broken I'd say I did a
good job brother
glad you're okay sorry for your
helicopter it wasn't really mine sorry
for crashing into your house it's not
really mine hey you think you could
lower that gun now I mean you've no harm
who's you look harmless alright thanks
my name is David Katherine or just Kate
do you think you could help me with
something David yeah how could I say no
to a pretty lady with a loaded gun in
her hand I'm trying to get somewhere an
outpost kind of outpost the one that
could help me leave this place leave
this world oh lady you okay you sure you
didn't hit your head during that crash
they have a spaceship oh yeah spaceship
I still have this gun you know wait
you're serious about the spaceship dead
serious sod real Plexus the corporation
they owned a whole fleet of ships when
things went nasty they used those ships
to evacuate their top researchers and
some of the richest people off the
planet I know for a fact there is still
one ship left on earth and I plan on
using it to escape you can come with me
if you want wait a minute that's an
awful lot of process you're telling me
there's a way out of here said the Joker
to the thief huh
listen I can take you there and you'll
see for yourself okay uh right who are
you exactly
just a girl trying to survive okay but
what's with this spaceship the outposts
and all that stuff you seem to know a
lot listen I'm a person that's going to
escape this hole before it goes to hell
with or without you
that's awful lot to trust just a random
stranger that you crash it into the
house of peace I saw that flip there's a
pickup truck in the barn are you trying
to impress me or something well we could
use it to get to that outpost of yours
god you're mean I guess we could oh come
on I'm coming up with good ideas here
your helicopter exploded do you think
the moon is going to destroy the earth I
don't think it I know it the moon's
orbit has been unstable even since the
incident I've noticed lately that it's
been getting bigger every day yes it's
gonna fall down and wipe everything out
it's gonna turn the whole planet into a
ball of molten lava nothing can survive
no matter how deep and tough a shelter
you have do you know when in three or
four days what I thought it's more like
years away I'm sorry but that's the main
reason we have to get to that spaceship
all right so what kind of spaceship is
it like a giant Ark that can travel
between stars like in the movies no
nothing like that the small ship capable
of getting to Earth's orbit but that
should be enough but what happens next
once we reach orbit there's a space
station you're not making it all up as
you go Daria I'm telling you there is a
space station where everyone went that's
our destination but don't worry about
that for now first we have to survive
for long enough to actually get there
all right so what is this out posteriors
it's a small research facility with a
spaceship launch platform okay where is
it I don't know what do you mean you
said you can take me there yeah but it's
not that easy why all the helicopters
navigation systems got smashed to bits
when it crashed and this output doesn't
exactly have a bright neon arrow
pointing to it the fact that it remains
are hard to locate places our only
choice of finding ships still there so
what do we do then we have to find it at
some point let's try to stay alive until
we do I had a dream alright here's my
map I have a map maybe looking at it
would give you a clue where that outpost
could be hmm no sorry I don't read maps
god you're so needy okay however what
while flying over this area I saw some
places that looked interesting here let
me mark them for you on your map that I
can trade let's see there was a
restaurant off to the west it was also
this house right here I think someone
still lives there maybe this information
will turn out to be somewhat useful okay
I know that this might sound weird but I
had a bad dream yesterday and it came
true a swarm of deadly locust has moved
through this area eating everything in
his path well the dream almost came true
because I died in that dream in reality
I took it as a warning and prepared
myself for the threat a dream you say
yeah I know
I'm not making it up that really was
some sort of prophetic dream it saved me
because I knew what to expect I don't
even believe in stuff like that I'm not
crazy person oh yeah okay I do believe
in dreams oh good yeah the lady who
crashed into my Altima the helicopter
and wants us to go get a spaceship go to
the moon believe some dreams too you
know we have so much in common
do you like space you do yes does it
make me a crazy person I don't know
makes you a crazy person definitely but
I think sometimes dreams can guide us or
help us find a solution that we
otherwise can't find yeah okay Nana
makes sense Baro it's Dave's dream so
tonight I had another dream or last
night whatever I was still here in this
house and all of a sudden there was Heat
Surge it got so hot it killed me on the
spot I think this might happen tonight I
must sound like a lunatic I know but
trust me I know I'm right we're gonna
find out ourselves if you're right
so what do we go what are we gonna do
about it what do you what do you what do
you mean we're gonna find out what do
you mean let's go then we should prepare
for your prophecy what about that
outpost it's out there we'll keep a
lookout for it but you say in three or
four days what if I get a dream that the
moon comes exploding all over my face
all right whatever I'll take the
screwdriver Tommy excuse mood see the
machine had one rough landing or roofing
to be precise this machine is totally
wrecked there's nothing I can do about
it what about some Salvage meat that
commie goods good excuse me excuse me
Kate yeah sorry I'm standing so close
about this place so what do you think
about our hideout
it's decent high ground solid walls not
too many windows it has a large
helicopter shaped hole in the roof
though you're skillful observations
amazed me oh thanks yeah you should try
my sarcasm next it's getting hot your
dream seems to be fulfilling itself
is this just cuz we're standing so close
together it's getting hot and heavy are
you gonna kill me on the spot is that
how this is gonna go down if that's the
case there's going to be a surge of
extreme heat right after it gets dark
what could have caused it
well Earth's climate is chaotic mess
this sort of thing happens more and more
frequently now I don't believe that
why would no I don't believe that
there's no reason though it happened all
right what are our dreams we got it it's
probably a temporary event temperature
should be back to normal tomorrow I hope
we get to see that happen of course we
will
as I said David I have plans hey call me
mark it's okay not David it's mark
places to visit a spaceship to grab risk
of heatstroke ain't gonna stop me okay
but it was kind of like an incineration
of entire existence see you around
gosh you smell nice alright see ya
alright don't mean to be a weirdo oh hi
okay alright what do you think of this
location huh alright I see okay
well how'd you beat me down here that
doesn't make a lot of sense hey I gotta
get these nails
Vasek Ogden nails remove the
reinforcements from this window
yeah probably gotta right yeah let's do
it together the barricade was not
salvageable that's fine it didn't need
to be okay hey give me a hand with this
what do you think of my bathroom pretty
good right pretty good you know what I
mean Kate because you can't you know
what I mean I am gonna see you I'll be
okay later what do you think about
computer you like it okay I'll write
down what I write in my journal I met
the helicopter pilot her name is Kate
she's so pretty she says she knows the
amount pasta with a spaceship that could
be used to leave the planet I have no
idea what her plan is and she isn't very
talkative about it I have to find my way
to cool down the heat oh okay all right
you just stop in so gosh-darn beautiful
you heating up the place Hey look at
this I guess I'll just you know I was
just hammer you like it helped okay cool
all right should I put these aways the
question or should I carry it with us I
mean I probably shouldn't carry with us
because I'm probably gonna need a lot of
stuff Oh a water sprayer what if I had
put pesticide in that and then I would
add localized pests huh okay whatever
not important all right so we need to
but above it above it about what do we
need to do I need to put some more stuff
oh no we'll have the truck okay cuz
we'll have the truck I can have the
truck storage how's this thing doing is
it dad seems dad seems to be dead I'm
gonna put it away unless I need to carry
it with us
oh that's a lot of dead bugs see all the
dead bugs whoops really high really high
really high okay let's get in the car
this place stinks oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
that my hideout stinks - you ungrateful
alright whatever let's go always got to
go on first realise really about this
place how do you like the bridge Kate
it's more like a gangway if we make a
second one like the first it would be
crossable with a car I think oh that
seems useful good thing I forgot the
nails hahahaha good thing good thing
right good thing good thing okay anyway
I got going I'll be back oh god damnit
of course I forgot the [ __ ] nails uh
yeah
alright let's do this come on you me
we're gonna get this crossable bike car
definitely stable alright let's do this
there we go now we're talking now we're
talking now we're cooking with the spice
all right so let's go - ah let's go to
the restaurant first burger huh I guess
I'm not worried about eating in this
game but maybe I would be okay what do
you think it is blaze pretty good right
so what do you think of this place I saw
it in from the helicopter and thought it
didn't look too bad
now I know better you've got to admit it
looks solid with all those missing
windows it doesn't have any advantages
of our hideout our hideout
it's also pretty much completely looted
there might be a thing or two left let
me know if you find any coffee okay
alright sure
okay I'll be back oh hi hello oh boy
hello go away I saw this place first I'm
warning you I know how to fight
[Music]
calm down we're not here for to hurt you
yeah this man over here is pretty
harmless alright okay whatever I'm not
afraid of you my name is mark this is
Kate what's your name
Cody now go away or else all right Cody
um where are your parents
nowhere I'm on my own I'm so sorry don't
be I've always lived on my own I know
how to take care of myself
all right go air what I'll beat you up
Oh No yeah so stay away please you seem
to be really persistent on opening that
door what's behind it what do you think
stupid it's a restaurant do you think
there might be some food there for sure
let's team up the weather is good real
dangerous at night you have better
chances with us do you have any food
maybe then maybe I'll team up with you
guys well [ __ ] if not I have better
chances on my own all right okay
whatever you say
find out what's over here stop don't
come any closer go away I'm not going to
you I'm going to we're going this way
can I not go this way okay all right I
get it okay you don't you don't even
want to know me I see out is lame okay
let's go to the back of the restaurant
seems to be something here ooh a rope
the flag's rope is stuck it's held by a
metal clamp I have to release it first
part of isn't missing I need something
with a round profile that could active
his lever ah short pipe this pipe fits
perfectly into the opening who'da thunk
all right there there we go
I'll take that then Oh easy good thing I
carried that on me Oh take that pipe it
seems that the pipe is stuck here for
good
Oh all right then well that's sad um
what do we got in the trash container
it's too heavy definitely not I'm too
weak definitely not that okay get it hey
Liz
can you help push container real weak
mark do you have any clue how stupid
your ideas are see that window over the
door I could squeeze through it but I
have to be able to reach it first you
should have started with that I'll help
you for the sheer fun of watching you
try to squeeze through that window all
right well you don't need to be rude
about it
sure now see if you can climb it without
breaking your leg see you know you said
you weren't gonna be rude and now you're
here just keep being more rude I'm going
the small window then squeeeeeeze
alright what is that portable air
conditioner oh [ __ ]
well that'll help alright good
got a meet then that's pretty good canta
meet for the kid I guess
cut board cut board it's locked
well not for the likes of me hey get
your knife oh [ __ ]
alright I'm kind of full on stuff um
what we got the truck so that's good
maybe that'll help us it's locked the
glass seems to be hardened hammer to
break the shatterproof glass I mean yeah
what else would work break the fridge
open with a crowbar it's faster than
breaking the glass oh that's smarter I
mean yeah five minutes is five minutes
right five minutes helps yeah oh well
easy alright
I'll take these two bottles of water
that'll help I have a bottle of water
prepared to prevent dehydration okay
that's good oh hi how did you get in
there see I'm a wizard I'm David huh
what are you talking about
we've never met before no I talked with
you oh you must be mistaking me for my
twin brother David sure you are joking
right did you find any food in there
yeah you want a can of meat kid there
you go here take this what is that food
but how do I open this so that's how
you've been taking care of yourself huh
hand it back all open it for you somehow
I'm hungry well I can cut it I guess
it's not the best tool for this job but
it'll do ahh screwdriver maybe maybe
that would work it's not the best tool
30 minutes Jesus now about I won Pitt
it's not gonna crush it but shoot it
can't do that well I you don't know that
he weird this food can has no keyhole
I'm being sarcastic it's not weird at
all how about a little rock gonna crush
it not open it alright how about a
crowbar alright I know crowbars opened a
lot of things but not this time
alright fine I'll get back to you now
and dump some stuff in my my sack
pardon my sack I don't know why I
brought the bug transmitter but I did
I'm kind of a dumbass put the portable
air cone douche new up with the bottles
of water in their air sprayer that'll do
okay umm how the heck do I get it all
there's there's a house let me make sure
I got everything in here first oh let me
go to the restroom Oh God
Kate yeah um uh wow that was a lot of
bugs do I have an opportunity to use
this emitter or is it dead I bet if I
had a water sprayer full of pesticide I
could kill those bugs god dammit oh no
no no no are those the same bugs that
have been scattering around your hideout
nasty creatures they almost ate me
yesterday
well too bad they're blocking our way
now do you think we can do something to
get rid of them honestly this looks
almost like a hive I think we should
come back tomorrow the temperature will
either kill them or force them to move
so let's just get back here later oh
okay that makes sense otherwise I would
have tried to actually do something
about it okay alright let's make sure we
got everything in here kitchen you'd
think there would be some kind of a
utensil here but apparently not yeah no
okay alright alright let's go well I got
go to the house a ruined house perfect
oh hi a morning man oh geez oh god I'm
not gonna like this probably not please
leave just leave me alone I mean you no
harm
yeah he's pretty much harmless Kate
please stop saying that I'm very
dangerous yeah my name is mark you don't
look too good can you tell us what
happened I'm Barry it's about my wife
she she didn't make it last night she
died why God why her should have been me
you should have been me she's still
there in the house I don't know what to
do come on mark let's go this guy had
enough wait Barry what do you want tell
me about your wife she was the most kind
and wonderful person I've ever known she
was my entire world enough she's gone I
failed her I couldn't detect her it
should have been me you'd better not
stay here the temperature at night is
gonna get crazy come with us we can help
each other
sorry I see no reason to keep going I
might as well stay here and wait for
death then I can be with my wife again
your wife would want you to live that's
a bold claim I'm sure your wife would
want you to live you should keep
memories about her and you can only do
that while you live why do you care so
much if I live or die you don't even
know me true well we all have better
chances to survive if we stick together
hey I can
I can't leave my wife like this all
right that's all for now
ha ha it's locked and I doubt I could
pick her lever that lock I need a key ok
so I probably need a key from the guy
stop don't go near that house why
because it's mine leave hey how about I
go the back of the house you can't stop
me I told you don't go near that house
sorry please go away
well guess I could shoot the guy but
that wouldn't be nice would it yeah
that's probably not the best idea
probably definitely I don't know if it's
gonna let me do this he's deep in grief
what's the point in threatening him I
need to find something to make him want
to carry on alright fair enough
alright hey you want a can of meat I
can't do that alright well uh what do
you think okay so what do you think of
this place
you want me to be honest wait no forget
I asked alright not in front of Perry
hey could you distract our friend here
for a moment somehow oh I know how to
distract him no hey no no could you do
it without a gun all right mr. boring
Hey hmm propane you say and propane
accessories first I have to disconnect
the hose from the tank
the ends are slightly secured with some
lug nuts I needed to disconnect him
first okay
lug nuts disconnected the tank pick up
the tank take the hose don't mind me
just just slapping some stuff in my
truck that I happen to find hey could
you okay could you talk to him not with
the gun okay alright anyway see ya I got
a wouldn't want to be alright anyway
let's go in I guess oh geez oh no God
so you inked something Russells inside
the fan looks like a bunch of loose
screws or something I think it's broken
closet coat coat I don't need coats warm
coat that's the last thing I need no
whatever I'll take it bad she a book to
book the mysticism of Dreams recurring
nightmares are often considered to be
something more than just a dream there
are more than several documented cases
of nightmares actually coming true it
suggests they can be treated as sort of
warnings a prophetic dream doesn't have
to perfectly come to fruition more often
than not the dream is a metaphor a
projection of the unconscious mind that
has come in contact with information
about events that are yet
happen how is it possible one may ask
this question remains unanswered we live
in a world ruled by science and
dominated by technology if there are
some mystical things lying underneath
the veil of reality that control our
lives to a degree much higher than you
dear reader could ever imagine whatever
the case may be you remember that dreams
are more than they seem just like not
understanding physics doesn't make it
less real the fact we don't fully
comprehend dreams doesn't render them
irrelevant interesting a lighthouse by
the seashore the sky is dark and the sea
seems deep and cold is the foamy waves
wash the sand around the unlit
lighthouse for some reason this painting
makes me feel uneasy I think that's also
from another game that script welder
made I think she has a small locket on
her neck
okay just yonk Jonker Oni there's a
button on the front of the locket as a
note inside Barry I'm sorry if you're
reading this it probably means I didn't
make it please don't let it be your
demise remember me and live a good life
and when the time comes I know you'll
make the right decision yours Maggie
what decision is another part of the
houses collapse nothing but a pile of
rubble left all phone lines have been
dead for quite a while all right well in
a big blanket we don't need a big
blanket I don't need any of this still
warm
way to warm maybe I can cut it up into
something maybe I can like reverse burn
it might help yeah I think that's
everything well Tom I figured it would
be bad to walk out the front door give
golden locket to Barry
this belongs to your wife you should
look inside and where did you get it
uh there's a note inside I thought where
did you get it oh oh listen I there's a
note inside I think you should read what
it says did you sneak into my house to
touch my wife Oh
oh stop it did you Barry wait oh stop it
so you go through her stuff like a
scavenger you're so dead I'll shoot you
no way oh god Barry just read the
goddamn note do it please just read the
note my sweet girl
[ __ ] my honey why you I'm sorry for
taking that but I thought you should
have it no no I'm sorry I shouldn't have
gotten mad like that if it wasn't for
you I probably would have never seen my
wife final words it's her handwriting
for sure but when did she write it how
did she know sometimes people can sense
things before they happen right mark
it's almost like I've read a goodbye
letter letter that you've delivered it
thank you
your wife deserves a proper burial I I
can't I can't look at her like this
lifeless call I'll bury what are you
serious we don't have the time for this
man just just lost everything show him
some respect I'm not gonna ask for your
help with this just don't try to stop me
yeah I'll help I just hope we don't
waste too much time do you have a shovel
Barry huh yeah yeah I have one right
here okay thank you I don't wanna go too
long without saving I thought I thought
he was gonna be shot and there was some
sneaky way I could have gotten that note
to him but thankfully no okay I'm gonna
push more [ __ ] away I'm kind of running
out of space here good guess the fan you
don't mind if I take this fan do all
right your life I take this shovel do
you all right anything else in the
garage no okay
all right I should find something to
cover the body with I got a blanket find
something else to cover the body with
this blanket could be useful I swear oh
I don't know about that blanket bed
sheet there we go I've covered the body
with the bed sheet Kate could you help
me move Barry's wife yes sure let's take
her outside shovel this will take 90
minutes or 60 minutes
oof yeah but it's the right thing to do
I know there are some of you that are
like don't waste the time but listen I'm
a kind-hearted soul I am a shining
beacon of hope in this desolate desert
all that we see is death but I will not
let my morals squirm away from me thank
you for listening to my TED talk all
right let's do this
thanks for the help Kate well thanks a
lot
oh really I thanks for the help yeah
thank you oh thank you oh you did you
hurt your back or something are you sure
you
worked real hard there let's get Barry
to come here before I bury her all right
he still said hey yes come on
it's Timon okay thank you
she deserved at least that of course she
did come on Barry let's go where we've
got a plan sort of the first part of
this plan is to survive tonight all
right
I'll do it for her okay all right hey
all right I'm Barry listen I'll talk to
you about all this the house wait do you
have any other insight about this place
so that was your home huh yes I lived
here with Maggie for almost ten years
ten years in a place like this Wow
Kate hey used to be a nice place really
before partly collapsed at least maybe
it wasn't much even back then but for us
it was everything our little place on
earth all right about Kate our car uses
so much fuel I guess I'll talk it's
getting really hot yeah I'm all sweaty
I can tell I've always handled high
temperatures poorly are you sure it's
gonna get worse temperatures usually
drop in the evening not this time
the worst he will be just after sunset
that's not normal nothing here is barri
have you noticed the moon getting bigger
each day yeah I reckon our days are
numbered they are indeed but I'm not
giving up that easily
good for you so the plan is to find a
spaceship an escaped spaceship yeah I
know it sounds crazy Kate came up with
it I have no confirmation on the
spaceship but the whole world is crazy
this case plan isn't it yes what do you
think about it I'm not sure it's a long
shot but there's no other hope we got
nothing to lose right yeah pretty much I
guess what do you think about Kate I'm
not sure she seems pretty crazy and
definitely hiding something
oh well wouldn't want to say that to her
face you realize I'm literally next to
you right our car used so much fuel I
don't think it's normal
there might be a number of reasons for
that from fuel injectors to incorrect
tyre pressure might also be something
wrong with the engine could you take a
look sure Oh God can point out some ways
to improve your car's gas mileage you'll
be able to reduce fuel consumption
[Music]
not now risint peace all right let's get
me out of here um let's see we helped
the man named buried to bury his
deceased wife he decided to follow us
anything else that we need probably not
gotta figure out a way to get that kid
to come with us
but I've got so much [ __ ] I want to drop
some of it off I can always come back
there's plenty of time for that I think
anyway there's the place you stayed at
yeah it's big Luke solid despite Kay's
best attempt it still stands and I think
it can provide us with the protection we
need at least until we figure out what
to do with the next I knew the people
who lived here really I'll tell you
about them if you want yeah I guess let
me drop so far first okay so we got this
blanket I guess we don't need the knife
maybe this is like a can open in the
kitchen or something something in the
kitchen no you said you knew the people
who lived in our hideout
we weren't really close but we spoke on
occasion what happened to them I always
wondered the house was locked and I
didn't find any bodies so I guess this
set of keys I found must have been
spares they left the military was still
trying to evacuate civilians from the
endangered areas until they realized
there was no safe areas left didn't you
want to go with them we were refused
Maggie wanted to stay now I wonder what
if and again I have no idea what
happened to the ones who left over there
all right but I doubt they are what do
you think of our hideout what can I say
it's okay it's bigger than my house used
to be I think it was a nice place before
the world ended still a good shelter a
shelter yeah home yeah you shall be a
home to some people it's now like an
empty shell of a turtle that once lived
Oh Barry I didn't know you were so
poetic all right god there's nothing mmm
yeah all right so first things first I
need the gas cuz I'm gonna need a refill
and I'm pretty sure I need a generator
because we're gonna need power tonight
in order to fend off the heat because
we've got a portable air conditioner all
this jazz so I got a dump the fuel into
the the thing come over here blow doink
fuel generator now have to start it um
let's not start it just yet now I've got
the empty canister let's grab some more
stuff from here this crap the flag for
some reason rope water water sprayer
I'll figure out what to do with it later
I just got a dump at all okay I'm gonna
head back I can't think of exactly what
I need to do at this juncture
but I'm gonna head back to the kid I
figure something out well grab some more
fuel on the way back
Hey hi Donna do you know how to talk to
this kid um anything at this place you
know in all these years living just a
bit down the road I never visited here
any particular reason Maggie my wife was
a great cook
you should have tasted her steak or a
grilled chicken with pasta she was she
was anyway I never ate here but looking
at this place from close up I don't
think I miss much so all I got to do is
open this right I guess it doesn't
matter if it takes long not the best
tool for the job
oh did I leave my knife oh god damn it
oh I did I left the knife all right
whatever let's do this let's do this I
left the knife it take longer to get it
back I open the can of meat right here
take it
here's the meat what is that food wow
you are a good person after all
I wouldn't say good maybe a bit clumsy
and soft god damn it Kate jeez you're so
mean come with us Cody you'll be safer
we might even have more food awesome so
you've been all on your own until now
pretty much yeah well now it's gonna be
different
you should be safer I'm Barry by the way
Cody those two Mark and Kate they've
helped me get through some sad moments
oh they are nice yeah hard to find that
these days hey if you're still sad do
you want some of that canned food thanks
kid but I don't need it it's all yours
yummy okay let's go then okay sure
yeah what do you think of this place I
saw from distance I thought they'd have
hamburgers I like hamburgers you don't
look like you've had many all skin and
bones I didn't find any hamburgers here
obviously you kind of know the rest it's
hot isn't it yeah it's really hot I'm
melting
is there any lake nearby or maybe a pool
yeah pool would be amazing can we look
for one I don't think that we have time
for that
what's so hot I'm sure I could swim the
pool faster than you I give up
I won't even try congratulations yeah I
won hey kid how old are you I'm not a
kid okay I'm 12 is that so
all right I'm 10 so what I know I did
two here myself I'm sure you do have you
noticed the moon getting bigger each
night no is it yeah why because it's
coming down right at us whoa oh great
thing to tell kid
wouldn't be bad for us yes it is hey
mark stop scaring him how bad we're
gonna be just fine Cody what do you
think about Barry I don't know he seems
nice but sad you
his wife you know I'll give him
something to cheer him up but I don't
have anything let's just give him
understanding in our company will that
be enough I hope so
better be put it's all we got what do
you think about Kate she's nice just
that simply nice nice and pretty all
right let's stop it there all right good
enough I guess but well do we have
everything that we need see we found a
starving kid Cody and give him some food
leaflets one of these do you have a
relative that has fallen into a coma do
you feel lost confused overwhelmed come
with us we will help Oh sidereal Plexus
sleeper clinic is our latest attempt to
reach out to people in need we provide
professional 24/7 care our specialized
personnel are looking after our patients
day and night bring your relative
register them with our Clinton and we'll
handle the rest
we don't want your money we want you to
be happy don't think that's what they I
don't think so is a safe haven for
sleeping family member we have also
recorded the highest wake-up rate of all
similar clinics during recent months
don't hesitate don't wait we will look
after your loved one during their long
and calm deep sleep Oh deep sleep script
welders author game
Kate could they then have something to
do with the outpost you're looking for
word because it says sidereal plexus
just because it says sidereal plexus
doesn't mean anything sidereal plexus
has more branches and you could imagine
I had no idea that we're running a
facility like this for instance
but it's only more disturbing when I
think about it why forget it it doesn't
matter let's keep going
Oh guys little weird but alright let me
just double check make sure that I got
everything here all right well thanks
for coming guys
I guess we gotta get out of here I don't
know what the hell we're gonna do I
really have no idea alright so we need
to go get gas number one monkey wrench
this bad boy fill er up hey guys you
don't have to follow me everywhere you
know alright guys thanks for helping
thanks for all the help thank you for
helping thank thank you.thank help thank
for the help and you guys know about
this place I used to feel my car here a
good price and feel quality was terrible
I don't think it's changed much since
then we could be fussy miracle this fuel
is still here
yeah about Cody what do you think about
Cody poor boy alone oh let's go inside
real quick is there anything else in
here I don't think anything else would
have appeared in here Kate what do you
think of this place saw from the air
realize it probably I don't have any
helicopter fuel part from the fuel tank
this hole is pretty much useless think
what we can to move on alright
uh what do you think about Barry no not
at all I know that look really we've
known each other for how long several
hours Oh
maybe still fine that guy is annoying me
I know he lost his wife but it's all he
talks about I'm tired of that we have
more important things to do than listen
to a morning man it's kind of harsh
I'm harsh get used to it yeah I've
noticed Kate you're so mean we think
about Cody yeah poor kid it's a miracle
he survived this long all right thanks
for your talk all right let's fuel her
up I'm gonna fuel up and then I'm gonna
go redo okay got that
all right so we got fuel the truck is
full and I've got a fresh tank so what I
can do is just to check just to check we
can go to the roadblock just because I
want to make sure there's nothing else
there that I've overlooked I don't think
there'll be whoa the bodies are gone
interesting huh interesting
ah okay what's up kid why did the tiger
lose at poker oh god I don't want to
hear this I don't know why cuz he was
playing with the cheetah great yeah
that's wonderful I hate everything all
right tire tracks these tire tracks
weren't here yesterday the road ahead is
blocked maybe someone was trying to go
around the crash site that's possible I
guess let's follow the tracks and see
where they take us that's my life motto
goodbye
oh okay and RVA well interesting Oh God
looks like their trip didn't end well
jeez I wonder what happened
my guess is their car broke down RVs are
not the best suited for off-road travel
you know they set a camp and then the
locusts swarm got him oh man it looks
like they buried the other bodies - he
doesn't have anything interesting
nothing much I can do for that poor guy
are you sure you don't want to bury him
because we have so much time on our
hands Kate we buried Barry's wife to
help him so why are they not worth
getting their own funeral don't be
snarky okay of course they're worth it
we just don't have the time
hear that sorry guys past our grave
digging time for today sees Katherine
you're kind of being a meanie he's dead
no valuable belongings cave well let's
check the RV first two boughs water
right um first aid kit no there's some
stuff in this first aid kit that's good
it was a bandage in there something more
thermal blanket nothing else so okay
well that's something a big blanket no
all right uh driver's seat before I try
to do anything else with it I should
inspect the car first inspect the RVs
engine this will take some time
three minutes that's easy the engine
seems fine but the suspension is busted
your RVs not going anywhere
and I don't think there's anything I can
do to fix it also the internal battery
for appliances seem to be working but I
don't know much how much did you sit as
the battery is charged when the engine
is running okay so I need to fuel it is
what you're saying something's wrong and
we'll start with the engine fuel perhaps
yeah makes sense
let's fuel her up I just so happened to
bring some I'm so smart I'm gonna take
this hook the hook is attached to the RV
with big bolts well I got a big bolt
thing I always carry it on me for some
reason there we go I've detached hook
alright thank you for saying that out
loud the sake won't solve any of my
problems without anything to plug it
into why would I need to plug anything
into it maybe light for the cave if I
needed that alright so now I should be
able to start it I've started the RVs
engine so so what about that it's at
least seven feet deep and I really don't
want to jump in there did I bring the
rope I didn't bring the rope okay well
that's fine
interesting so there's something that we
have to do number one we got to hook
something up to this apparently but we
need a rope first to do anything so
let's just do that first I didn't bring
the rope god dammit okay four minutes
five percent fuel not bad okay so we're
gonna go at the rope rope a bandage
thermal blanket a lot of warm stuff but
not enough cold stuff cold is what we
need bottle of water for everybody I
guess I mean an extension cord but why
would we need an extension cord
let me save before I go too deep in this
rope not really a [ __ ] rope and hook ah
I could use this to get the rope down
but I need to put it in the crack and
the rocks above the cove oh okay alright
there we go I've inserted the hook into
the crack it's just there firmly it
should be safe to use the rope alright
well let's go down no don't remove that
god damn you to hell
there we go
all right now let's go down cave burr
it's really cold down here that's good
maybe we should be here tonight okay
what do you think of this place really
cold David if you were looking for a
place that I couldn't compare to a hole
in the ground you found it there's
literally as a hole in ground there's
nothing here just severe cold severe
called you say aha and then the thing
the thing oh my god it all makes sense
we're not supposed to stay at the house
tonight cold like Kate's heart hey what
it's an accurate description I think I
have to agree you could have said it's
dark like our future or its bottom is as
hard as life has recently become or
they're shallow like our current
discussion well maybe if you weren't so
mean wouldn't be a problem about this
place what do you think about this cave
it's golden near golden there
echo echo echo echo yeah all right all
right freak you weirdo but this is good
okay this is good what we can do I
didn't bring the extension cord but this
is good I can bring Brit basically
everything that we need down here so I
think I'm about ready to go right aren't
we just about ready so what I definitely
need to do is okay we need to go back to
the house number one and we need to get
the rest of the stuff everything that
we're gonna need to survive right so
we're gonna need you the water we need
four bottles of water that's gonna help
we need the fan a broken fan how do we
fix the fan well as you saw it the
inside of the fan is some loose wires
and screws getting this thing to work
won't be easy oh well we got everybody
so why not cool so the fans working we
need the portable air conditioner
definitely we need the extension cord a
thermal blanket I don't think that's
gonna help I don't think the blankets
are gonna help at all but maybe I'll
bring anything temperature related that
we have there just in case because I do
not know what's gonna be useful and
what's not okay I think I got everything
I need but I do have enough time to go
back if necessary okay so let's grab the
extension cord let's grab all the
electronic stuff put the extension cord
plug that bad boy in or should I take
the end of the court ah into cave duh
Bert's really cold down here well it's
about to get colder baby our fan on oh
yeah all right I put an electrical fan
in the cave fueled and started an RV any
appliance is connected to it should
much longer now all right portable air
conditioner there we go before I plug it
in I should install it by the caves
opening you know what you right you
right
okay but I should have installed it
while in the cave what no I shouldn't
solve wily no no oh here oh there we go
okay all right air conditioner plug
first I take the end of the extension
cord boink and bonk
okay installed inserted the air
conditioner in the cave good blanket
well I won't need the blanket we don't
need the blanket it's gonna get hot
maybe I could try to like block up the
entrance use thermal blanket you could
cover the caves hole with a thermal
blanket and secure it in place using
some dirt and rocks but it's gonna take
time
oh yeah I guess let me see what else we
got
I need to give the divvy up the bottles
of water first
okay bottles of water who wants water uh
okay Barry I have some water thanks but
I think you should give one to Cody
first I'm gonna give it a Cody Cody why
do you got to be in a weird place that I
can't get to take this water wow thanks
or save it for later when the water gets
weather gets really hot alright now
Barry can you take this I have some
water for the heat should help all right
now hey sunshine hey how you doing
here's some water
alright I'm not really thirsty though
save it for later for dehydration I know
Thanks yeah you do you know do you know
do you really know give Kate about water
Cody
I gave Barry a bottle of water he's big
so he might need it more than anyone
else maybe I need to give Barry two
bottles but what about me I need a
bottle of water um I don't think anybody
needs coats or blankets I don't think
anybody needs either those things we got
time so the thing is we have time we
have five hours left
I need more fuel number one just because
I don't like not having fuel
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna talk to Barry
about making the car more efficient oh
[ __ ] we got to go to his house okay
we'll hang on a second we're getting
close we're getting close we're getting
close we're getting real close there we
go and now she's much less fuel
oh hell yeah so let's go by the house
one last time cuz we got time so I just
gotta think if there's anything in there
that we need to keep I should probably
lock up the house to make sure there's
nothing upstairs that we need hey you
guys want to see how Kate [ __ ] up you
guys want to see that you guys wanna see
it
wow it's so awesome I flew it you know
you flew it in here helicopters are cool
can I get inside not the best idea kid
but don't touch it don't even come near
why because it might fall I wouldn't
want you to fall and hurt yourself
coming after my wife died I heard your
helicopter I walked outside just in time
to see you fly over the house yeah I
wasn't sure if the place was abandoned
or not
why didn't you land there if you were
low on fuel I was trying to touch down
this baby since I had flown it past the
city it was not particularly operative
those bullet holes it's a long story
okay
all right goodbye okay so that's pretty
much all I can think of I'm sure I've
forgotten something but I think this is
gonna be a lot better than what it was
so I think it'll be fine yeah I'll be
fine
all right we'll try we'll see what
happens we're pretty close I think we
got pretty much everything oh wait wait
wait wait wait whoa I don't need this
anymore ah okay I thought maybe I could
take care of the bugs but apparently not
okay let's go the RV so I don't have to
worry about this thing's fuel level
right weight closet ooh almost missed
this okay a jacket we don't need jackets
well that would be jackets for everybody
yeah we don't need them big ol waist
nothing needed I think we got everything
a water sprayer we could hook that up
with some water and spray someone with
it aha
I think I think we're I think we're
there I think we're there let me just go
ahead and do it I'm gonna do it i'ma
stop pussyfooting around I'll stop my
pussyfooting around and I'll just do it
here we go done okay
now there there we go yeah I think
that's it right what else could we
possibly need I don't I don't see how
there's anything else that we could
possibly take advantage of so go save
one last time because I'm particular and
then pick one item from your inventory
that you'd like to equip during the
night or cancel it if you don't want a
bottle of water oh the desert usually
gets cold in the evening but not this
time the heat search was incredibly
strong as the wave of boiling hot air
moved through the land you found shelter
in a cave underground hoping it would
save you from the deadly heat the caves
entrance was covered with a thermal
blanket cutting off a lot of the heat
the cave proved to be a good shelter as
it shields 35% of the initial heat wave
a portable air conditioner was placed in
the cave with its pipe stretching above
the ground if the cool air dispersed
about 26 percent of the heat wave you
plugged in electric fan the cave the air
circulation helped 24 percent you gave
k2 bottled water drinking enough fluids
really important it surely helped her
give Cody
if berry you had a bottle warm and
unpleasant but wet work to help the roof
percent 5% it was hot but not too hot
you prepared well oh but it wasn't
perfect well screw that noise I go for
perfection here the Frick did I miss
5% what did I miss that was 5% maybe it
is the water sprayer maybe it's the
water sprayer that might be at the water
sprayer if I can put the water bottle in
the water sprayer then I know I'm on the
right path then I know I'm on the right
path then I know I'm on the right path I
should have tried it I don't know why I
didn't try it look of course it makes so
much sense
okay it makes sense when you think about
it it was only 5% it's gotta be
something tiny as in like the difference
between how oh freakin 5% what am i
messing oh there's no food in here only
some weird shaped tile objects I wonder
what those are I didn't look in the
freezer I didn't even know there was a
freezer
he'd absorb all go my god oh my go heat
absorber tile oh how convenient a heat
absorber tile would be well good for us
well I might as well go fill up on gas
freakin freakin the trunks I've been
driving around for no reason
okay alright whatever we're just gonna
go it's totally fine
I'm worried for nothing okay BRR it's
really cold down here yeah well it's
about to be colder I click the view what
exactly is that thing anyway looks like
a thick ceramic tile maybe something on
the back from our spaceships to your
kitchen sidereal plexus brings the heat
absorber tile exciting new technology
allows his towel to absorb huge amounts
of heat cooling the temperature around
it warm beer broken refrigerator never
again just apply pressure into the tile
by hitting with something blunt like a
hammer to activate it the tile will
start absorbing heat for up to 16 hours
in fact may vary depending on the room
temperature right good alright I think
this thing really absorbs the heat yeah
do I put it on the wall oh I guess I
could give it maybe on the top no okay
Oh drop this I didn't see that okay drop
this item to set it up okay sure yeah
that makes sense okay it makes sense it
makes sense it makes sense it makes
sense drop drop drop okay and yeah
okay good everybody gather round it's
good great I placed three heat absorbers
in the cave great okay guys gather your
water kiss your butts goodbye because
it's about to get a little toasty okay
it's about to get a little toasty that's
thirty five percent from that twenty six
percent from that twenty four percent
from that heat absorbers twenty-one
percent of that oh well it wasn't as bad
as you thought it would be conditions to
the outside were harsh but in your
hideout everything was absolutely fine
you didn't even sweat much you were able
to rest much more comfortably than you
thought you would yes yes I've getting
stronger oh oh [ __ ] what are we gonna
deal with next time lot of day oh [ __ ]
hi so you had another bad dream Wow look
at those corpses yeah not a very
pleasant one there were these people
thugs
bandits they raided our hideout they had
guns they wanted to kill us so I have to
defend ourselves what is it Cody you
seem excited I have something important
to tell you
it's like super duper important we have
to prepare for tonight even more than
yesterday
yes Cody I know you don't know why yet I
don't I thought
sheesh I had a dream there were like
dozens zombies coming towards the house
they wanted my brain we have to protect
it I don't want to be eaten they had
those ugly faces and they were slowly
walking with their arms in front of them
they were speaking to me all like birds
Cody zombies aren't real you had a bad
dream that's all what know why your
dreams are better than mine I'm not
saying they are better so you believe me
that there are zombies coming after me
no one is chasing you Cody zombies will
think you're tasty mark there's
something I have to tell you I also had
a dream you saw what I saw no I saw city
I know where to find the spaceship mark
or at least I know how to look for it
what where sidereal the corporation that
built these ships had a number of
outposts and offices across the well
everywhere actually in my dream I saw
one of them in a deserted City to the
southwest it was just an office but if
we get there we might find the location
of the space
about post so you don't know for certain
market have I doubted your dreams for
one second I need you to trust me on
this one we've got to get there as soon
as possible before we spend any time
preparing for what's coming tonight well
okay we'll save that for next time so
thank you everybody so much for watching
this is getting weird
but I love it I love this this is so
cool like the concept of don't escape is
something I've really loved for a long
time and to see it actually be brought
into a bigger game like this is so cool
I love this so thank you everybody so
much for watching look forward to the
next day very soon in the next part and
as always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]